The first proposition that they make is
that we should treat the reality that
we're dealing with as psychologists.
We should treat human experiences,
that reality.
And so the reality for you
from a phenomenological
perspective is everything you
experienced,
they assume everything
you experience is real.
And they also assume that you can't
actually get more real than that.
And so your consciousness,
whatever that is,
is real and your dreams are real and
your emotions are real and your pain is
real,
which is a really useful thing to think
if you want to make sure that you're not
going to hurt people.
You know,
you kind of have to think that maybe
fake pain should be treated as a
fundamental reality instead of as an APP.
That phenomena of some material substrate.
And so that's their first perspective.
And they took that from Heidegger
because Heidegger thought that western
philosophy had gone off,
got off on the wrong track,
you know,
3000 years ago.
Um,
because we didn't really concentrate on
being itself as the fundamental mystery.
And so the fundamental mystery is
why the hell is there anything?
And since there is
something experiential Ba,
what are its fundamental elements?
And so that's the phenomenological stats.
It's,
it's completely,
it's not the same as a scientific approach
because it starts with a different
presupposition.
You know,
the scientific presupposition,
roughly speaking is that things are the
objectively real elements of things are
the most real elements.
And there's no sense complaining about
that because it's a approach that works
tremendously well for many,
many things including making
hydrogen bonds for example.
But it's also reasonable to think that,
well it might not be the,
it might not be the whole truth
and nothing but the truth.
And maybe you could also suspect that
the fact that we can manufacture hydrogen
bonds also might indicate
that there's something,
a trifle off with our
fundamental belief systems,
scientific though they may be.
And that was certainly something
that concerned Heidegger,
even though he got all
tangled up with the Nazis.
So the phenomenologists were trying to
take a part experience as such and they
made some some hypotheses
and then some observation.
So the first is that we're going to assume
that your experience like experience
itself is real.
Now you just because dreams
are real and pain is real,
it doesn't mean,
and like objects that we can all perceive
our real doesn't mean you should put
them all in the same category.
Like my dreams are not in
the same category of reality
as this table because you
don't have access to my dreams
and you have access to the table.
But that doesn't mean that my dreams and
my pains and my emotions aren't real.
They're real.
So that's the first.
Now I,
you should know that this is a,
this is a proposition.
What they're saying is let's act as if
that's true and then worked from those
premises and see what happens,
see where we can get with it.
And that that's,
that's a reasonable thing to do
because at the bottom of a theory,
you also have,
you always have to put an
assumption because otherwise
your theory would be 100%
right and would cover
everything and it doesn't.
So you have to throw an assumption
somewhere in there at the bottom and say,
okay,
we're not,
we're not questioning that.
That's the starting point.
So you have to do that
because you're ignorant.
You don't have a full theory.
So they don't like the idea that
mind can be reduced to matter.
They're not playing that game.
They're not playing the game that the
subject is only up phenomenal and the
object is real.
They don't play in that game either.
And it's partly because as
bosses without a subject,
nothing at all would exist to confront
objects and to imagine them as such.
True.
This implies that every object,
everything objective is merely objective
in being merely objectivize by the
subject is the most
subjective thing possible.
It's a radical claim,
you know,
but here's,
here's something to think about.
When I look at that code,
can you might say how I
perceive the object and then
I make inferences about its
use and then I evaluate
it and then I use it.
And you know,
that is not actually what you do.
In fact,
it's not obvious at all that
what you perceive our objects.
And if you think about it,
well,
people weren't perceiving
scientific objects until
like 1,514 50 so there was no
objective object before that.
So obviously whatever we were perceiving
was not precisely that because we would
have been scientists right off the bat,
George Kelly claimed that
people were natural scientists.
You know,
that we're always investigating hypothesis
and trying to disprove them and so
on.
And it's an interesting theory
and that it's right in a sense.
But fundamentally it's wrong.
We are not natural scientists
were natural engineers.
And when we look at the world,
we don't see objects.
And then in further use,
what we actually see is the use.
So for example,
when I look at that,
coke can,
my,
my visual system activates
my motor cortex directly.
It can do that without me seeing the
dam can consciously to some degree,
because there are people with blind sight.
I've told you about those people,
they say they can't see.
But if you ask them which
hand do you have held up,
they can tell you.
So they might not be able to see.
But they can map patterns from their
visual system onto their motor output.
You know?
And that's basically what Piaget said
we do when we deal with the world,
we're embodied creatures,
you know?
And so what we see when we
look around aren't objects.
They're things we can use and
things that get in our way.
You know,
and that's a theory that
was derived originally from
Jj Gibson who wrote a great
book on that called the visual approach
to ecological ecological approach to
visual perception.
And his science is a brand of pragmatism.
And the pragmatists basically
claim that you know,
things including theories and perceptions
have a limited range of truth and the
truth that,
that,
that the limited range of
truth is determined by the
match between your actions
and outcomes.
So I think this is a coke can,
is that what it is?
No,
but it's good enough for me if I want
to drink a bit of coke out of it.
God only knows what it is.
You know,
if you go into communist China and
you start advertising these things,
then what are they?
Cause this thing tells a story,
right?
What's the story like?
Really?
Do you need Coca Cola?
No,
it's like it's a bit of Frippery,
you know,
it's a bit of,
it's not unnecessary luxury.
It's not even very good for you,
but it's kind of fuzzy and it's
sweet and you get to buy it.
And why is that?
Because no matter how stupid you
are and your nutrition choices,
as far as our society goes,
you have the right to poison yourself
in whatever way you think best fits you.
And so when you send this little
coke can off to communist China,
this thing screams stupid
individuality all over.
And God only knows how
it undermines the state.
You know?
And if you don't,
if you're not thinking about that,
you're not thinking.
Think about what happens
when we export cars.
What does the car say?
It says,
Hey,
you can go wherever you want,
whenever you want.
You don't have to tell anybody at all
and you can do it in a really dangerous
high speed manner.
It's like you want a political statement,
wrap it up in metal and
ship that thing off.
And everybody goes,
Whoa,
I really liked to have one of those.
It's like,
poof,
communism disappears with that.
You know,
there's nothing that says
individuality and capitalism,
like a personal automobile.
You know?
You even get to pollute the atmosphere
and ruin the planet with the damn thing.
But you know,
if you have to drive to the corner
store and pick up your damn coke,
it's like to hell with the atmosphere.
Okay.